bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovi dire sono da dj oggi sono torna un
po di gente perché mi hanno sfrattato da
casa mia per fare ogni gol siamo qui
uniti perché è uscita la nuova web start
up collection dove ci siamo tutti quanti
questa è la mia e questa è quella di
sabrina è uscita ragazzi da pochissimo
in edicola trovate quindi già tutti 3
euro
quindi fate il mio video per cortesia
vabbè volevo anche dirvi che se trovate
dove la mia se trovate dietro perché ci
sono fatte così dietro se trovate dietro
la stella d'oro
potete ricevere un videosaluto ce ne
sono solo altro cioè sono solo sei gare
sarà esaminato il ruolo di pagarsi
posizionato aspetti collage anatel i
secoli franca tesi su in scena bravo
bravo taggare non potete farne a meno
come il pro loco e siamo sui mi colpì
che facciamo niente siamo il suo amico e
quindi facciamo miccoli per l'occasione
ovviamente nell'asia tipo il primo
youtube italia è unito il primo youtube
vero visa il primo io giusto fa per i
map perché privo youtube
quindi ragazzi andate in edicola e
trovate il magazine a in coop il link
descrizione di sotto vita tutte le
informazioni di cui avete bisogno e noi
possiamo iniziare con questa puntata di
un po specie infatti non è così secondo
me una sabrina con un sacco sul
sull'attività ha avuto la risposta
istantanea a latenza tele me vieni
dall'italia no vengo dal dall altra non
è così veloce nelle battute però
compensa venda dall'altra la lontra
i reati attente ditta di desiati veloce
no non ci credo però questi giovani
donne e lo so
ciao
ciao male perché i ragazzi vi avvicinate
ragazza cucina e ora vi nascondo mi vuoi
con la sedia buonasera giorni come mai
non è interessato a quanti anni aveva a
che vedere faceva la mente di bacino
[Musica]
presentazioni lorenzo sabrina salvo è
ignota tac mi chiamano el matador si
chiamano el matador ha ris
ciao
allora ci stava cercando il nuovo la
sera salve dai tagli netti
allora abbiamo dei problemi istanza se
ne sta accorgendo siamo siamo dei
ragazzi simpatici come stai bene come ti
chiami tu chiami francesca ho mai fatto
vivo ma non siamo incontrate ma c'è
sempre la prima volta ma sarà il potere
dei tata che stiamo facendo una specie
di domanda tutti quanti stanno cercando
di capire se ci sono altri gli elefanti
società di una domanda quasi venti metri
ha risposto al massimo quattro già
scritto nel mio elefante diventi mente
un posto nei quarti cuccioli poi una
scrofa al massimo 34 ma non è invece la
giochino funziona già scritto la marea
puntata di national geographic ovunque
c'è scritto nel mega timbaland
ecco vedete voi non potete parlare del
rasate 0
vai puoi scegliere uno degli altri mezzi
per fare una challenge messo online
allo stefano ti ammazzo rivendicazione
[Musica]
sì ma parliamo io e te come ti chiami
come ti chiami sardi dove sei
bologna bologna una nuova perfetto tutti
e miike sarà mi chiamano il matador ma
bologna la petizione città eh si proprio
per chi ci vive proprio come cc vive da
tanti papà vegas e proprio per 3 1
ciao sarà giuseppe per favore io sola
versione normale ma sto parlando con me
tocca punti non voleva che parlare tutti
al nord
non è la prima miss collection
ciao amore come stai
by many è contenta di 20 ragazzi e sono
tu puoi decidere di far fare a una
persona in particolare a una persona in
particolare un qualsiasi cosa che vuoi
stefani esterni devi fare che cosa devi
fare
[Musica]
ma no ma perché del giu non è come
sembra
[Musica]
ma no ripeto adesso trip e tesoriere i
trigger azzurri ciao mario
devo spoilerarvi una cosa infatti sono
in atac e sono tipo tesi riguarda sono
noti di young lad
o cosa si attaccano dove vuoi e li trovi
in edicola
[Musica]
si no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
quindi ragazzi è stata la puntata di un
amico in più più più strana del verde
tipico lo so però distrarre i nostri
auguri andate in edicola trovate i
nostri tata che cercate la stella d'oro
riceve il messaggio del messaggio altra
immaginari che cellulare in palio quindi
usate il codice direttamente sul
individuate con sottoscrizione saluti
non saprei che altro dire la figura di
attrezzatura più della famiglia e
travestì patto la tipa mir il tipo
50mila euro
ai moneta
[Musica]